[Applause]
all right now
let's all get a little quiet here for a
second you know one of the things kids
love
most about this time of year is going to
the mall and
sitting in santa's lap and telling him
what they want for christmas
well i love that myself as a child and
i figured you know i've got the suit on
why not give back some of the wonder and
joy
that i received as a child max would you
please
[Applause]
[Music]
well ho ho ho just a second little girl
ho ho merry christmas
children merry christmas elf
uh merry christmas santa the kids all
say they've been extra good this year
well i'll be the judge of that hi there
what's your name lindsay
lindsay hi now lindsay why don't you
tell santa
what you would like for christmas i
would like you to treat your guests with
more respect
what and stop fidgeting so much
oh right same note as the network
there you go thank you very much run
along here you go
hi how are you good what's your name
lisa
hi lisa now what would you like for
christmas i would like you to stop
wearing your tie
oh well look just forget about the show
for a second all right what else do you
want
i would like to see you punch an old man
in the stomach
okay well santa can do that right
all right ah
wait would you like me to hold him santa
yeah please do that
okay hi
oh you're a big boy what's your name
chris hi chris now what would you like
santa to bring you i'd like to i like to
see a nutty early aviation footage with
funny noises
oh well that's great i think santa can
do that let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there oh now what's your name whitney
whitney
all right whitney now what do you want
for christmas
i wish you'd stop fighting with java men
hmm you're right java man and i should
end our year-long feud man
no java man i i guess some of the things
i said were
a little out of line come on put it
there
ah all right very good thank you
man hey come on up here
how are you good to see you now oh boy
how about you what's your name first of
all mark mark all right now what would
you like for christmas i really like
to bring my daddy back bring your oh
bring your daddy back
make your d okay all right uh sure i can
do that max
max it's christmas the man's got a
family let him go home
right now yeah right now all right
there you go you must see your daddy
hey all right oh
boy what's your name ashley ashley
okay and what would you like for
christmas i would love to see
ed um
you'd love to see who
you'd like to see ed koch tickle himself
very
merry good everyone we'll be right back